autre dossier outre l'afghanistan pour
la diplomatie russe les relations de
moscou avec budapest vienne et rome le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
poursuit sa tournée en europe de l'ouest
en italie où se trouvent nos envoyés
spéciaux monnaie à bout dès lors et
renault parquet
à mona l'italie n'est pas le premier
pays visité cette semaine par sergueï
lavrov
exactement c'est une tournée européenne
qui s'achève pour le chef de la
diplomatie russe en italie après des
visites en hongrie et en autriche
ces êtres dernière étape est l'occasion
de renforcer les relations bilatérales
russo italienne demain est prévu un
entretien avec le premier ministre
italien mario draghi ainsi que des
négociations avec l'actuel chef de la
diplomatie italienne luigi di maio
l'opportunité pour elle les deux hommes
est d'échanger sur l'agenda
international et notamment sur un sujet
brûlant de l'actualité l'afghanistan
luigi di maio elle a confirmé la
situation à kaboul sera au centre des
conversations dès demain ce sera
également l'occasion d'aborder lé
questions européennes ainsi que
l'implication l influence de l'otan en
europe mais pas seulement il sera
question de la situation en ukraine en
libye ou encore au moyen-orient alors
après cette tournée européenne pas de
visite en france pour consolider est les
relations bilatérales ou même aplanir
les différends entre les deux pays après
un g7 exceptionnelle sur l'afghanistan
sans la russie dont le rôle est crucial
dans la région luigi et 10 maiolo ap le
ministre des affaires étrangères a
indiqué que le g20 qui se tiendra ici
même fin du mois d'octobre à rome sera
une plate forme multilatérale pour
trouver à des solutions en commune à
tous les défis qui vont se présenter
merci moi la mode alors pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de rome merci
également à renault parquet qui vous
accompagnent derrière meira